gavin newsom he's just this good-looking
kind of he's a pimp
mm-hmm he's just a pimp of a dude he
used to [ __ ] that chick kimberly
guilfoyle
yeah on fox news who now [ __ ] donald
trump jr
she's in it for love huh you say that
about kimberly
guilfoyle newsom she's in it for love
she's a woman that really likes a deep
emotional connection with the guy she's
with huh
that's what i think i'm just a casual
observer of her and yet that's what i
would feel
kimberly likes a man that's got a little
bit of cloud
kim likes some clout
did he get elected in california i
didn't even pay attention to california
before i [ __ ] lived here and i barely
pay attention now
i don't know why their marriage fell
apart
probably because he kept quarantining
her
he kept he kept he kept giving her state
home orders
kept issuing her stay at home orders and
curfews
she said i've had enough i want to go
[ __ ] donald trump jr and talk about q
anon
they're like openly promoting q anon
right now yeah donald trump jr is just
it's the last thing they have left
they're just they're just openly
promoting q
dude trump's gonna trump dude if the
last thing
it's the last thing he does if the
military has to walk him out of the oval
office
he just looks at everybody and he goes
i'm cue [ __ ]
that's the other thing about trump he
knows a good finale right it's all
reality tv
so he's got to do something big that's
why i tried to bomb iran
what's a big finale no he's going to
have a media company
it's so stupid he's given nothing he's
gonna leave
he's running again in four years it's
never it's not going to be over
dude i remember the senior year i had
some of the best
some of the most fun i ever had in my
life
i remember seeing your summer
hanging out with even during senior
summer you started to see the people
from your
your school less and less by the end of
senior summer you all kind of saying
goodbyes
and it was time for everyone to go away
to college except tim dillon who went to
nassau community college he's a [ __ ]
loser
uh but it doesn't matter because i
podcasted now with alex jones and
roseanne eat your heart out [ __ ]
um
i just love i go back to like give a
speech at my school i'm like
i've sat down with the greatest minds of
our generation
i have spoken to the greatest minds
to the minds of people that have shaped
our world how did i do that
how did i do that well i took drugs for
a decade
developed what some would call latent
schizophrenia
and then started started to
make connections with people that also
had that disease but were far more
successful than me
okay kids so take the student loans and
shove them up your ass
but that week when everyone was going to
school was like you know
august whenever you knew it was
over you could feel it
even when people were like nah man we're
all we're all gonna be
and then yes you know what's funny
the first thanksgiving uh
weekend everyone comes back that first
wednesday it feels a little different
maybe you're all still friends you're
also hanging out probably
but by the next year by the next
wednesday
when everyone goes out and a lot of
people listen you're like what do you
mean friends bars going out thanksgiving
i have no idea what you're talking about
well we know but
wednesday before thanksgiving like when
it's the next year
it's like sophomore year in college like
it's been one year it's you see people
they're like strangers to you and they
were like your best friends and like oh
my god you we have we have nothing in
common
you're gone you're at another school you
have new friends you have new
experiences you have
you know you have new things going on
and i had
i had nothing going i was so embarrassed
because i would go out and i was always
funny and people liked me but i
i was at a community college i was like
so embarrassed
that my friends were coming back from
universities i'm
still embarrassed i didn't go to college
and i've done better
than all of them have i not mentioned
who i've sat in rooms with
i mean i'm i'm a national media figure
myself candace owens alex jones
roseanne we are your media
you get it we're the media now oh you
don't like it
tech writer with purple hair [ __ ] off
no one cares what you like you
blue-haired freak
write any article you want i'm the media
[ __ ]
i am and dave portnoy
barstool sports and me
we're the media sorry we took it over
okay
you could tell the souls burger family
at the new york times to go [ __ ]
themselves
in their [ __ ] loafers and their boat
shoes
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm the [ __ ]
media but even though
i have a privileged position as a member
of our
as a proud member of our new media
i am still kind of embarrassed i didn't
go to college
and i think i should be forever i should
be a little embarrassed
not a lot about i know i did cool [ __ ] i
sold subprime mortgages i bought a house
i
i was in rehab i get it i did a cool
thing too
but even like little dan carney when
he's telling me about florida state and
the whole thing
i feel not you so much because you went
to that christian cult school
but when dan's talking about florida
state which is just a party school it's
not really a good school
but i feel like oh this is a college
experience i can't relate to that i
really can't right
so i feel a little almost insecure about
it that i didn't go to
college right not that i am much smarter
than most people who went to college i
didn't even choose to be
you know what i mean but i still feel a
little insecure about it which i think
is a healthy thing
i think it's a healthy thing to feel a
little insecure because it keeps me
grounded
as a as an all-powerful member of the
new media
i need to be a little grounded because i
don't want to lose touch with the people
you understand so i don't like to lose
touch with the people
that's why like roseanne smokes for
example she doesn't want to lose touch
with the people
but i was very embarrassed when i went
to
thanksgiving eve and i was like at a
community college and i had nothing
going on and everybody else was at
better
schools and they were like colle they
were like looked like college kids
and they came back and i was just kind
of like hey yeah i'm the same
you know nothing's going on in my life
but they're like what are you up to i'm
like i don't know
how did i win a did i win a debate
championship at national community
college
was it the first gold medal that that
school has ever won
yes 100 and did i defeat
two women yes i did yes i did
in the sport of talking i defeated
two ladies one white one asian
stomped them out at the national
tournament in philadelphia
stomped on their faces okay
in my ill-fitting cheap suit
but i knew it
you know and then and then obviously you
know like you know
you grow up you lose touch p you lose
touch with people they're gone they're
just gone
they go away it doesn't matter what you
want
i will say the debate part of college
for me
was the only thing that even resembled a
college experience
because when you were on the debate team
at nassau community college you got to
travel
to other colleges that like existed that
were real
and you would debate kids and then you
would get to go to a national tournament
at the end of the year the first one was
in los angeles
california have you heard of this city
have you heard of this place
it was in woodland hills
i stayed at the woodland hills marriott
my debate partner kenny who sold me a
house
that destroyed my life but i don't
really have any will towards him i still
kind of like him
because he was fun that's how much i
that's how much of a you know a uh
what what word am i looking for
when you say i put a uh uh i put a uh
premium that's how much of a premium i
put on someone being fun
you can sell me a house and destroy
a decade of my life as long as we
as long as you're fun in a car
we're good truly we're good so i like
him
but woodland hills
marriott debate national tournament
had sex with a woman for the first time
biological woman not
w-o-m-x-n an actual woman with an
a
white not la tinx sadly
would have been hot if i got a la tinx
latinx is it la tinx or latinx
latinx la tinx sounds like somebody's
name
yo you gotta call la tinx
la ting sounds like somebody's got good
coke real good fish scale
yo cola tinx you got the [ __ ] right now
and uh i felt like i started you know i
was like oh this is cool
and then the next year i went to
philadelphia and uh
that was the year i just wanted to win i
wanted to win i was all about winning i
was like i'm good at debate i want to
win this [ __ ]
and i smoked pot all weekend and i drove
around listening to
like beanie siegel that song in the air
you can feel it in there
driving around my shitty car and i won
i won the gold medal and it was the
first in our shitty community college
that looks like a prison that's
literally two blocks away
from a prison in long island first gold
medal in their history that's my college
experience there it is
right right there nothing really nothing
to write home about
i met a lot of great people at nassau
community college i met a woman who told
me something that haunts me to this day
chubby woman wore those like those like
terry cloth pants and flip-flops in
october
she was smoking a parliament light and
she goes listen people people think i
can't drink and raise my daughter i can
do both
haunts me to this day sometimes when i
lay my head on the pillow
i just think of that woman and what she
said
she said it's so nonchalantly to me
outside of our biology class we were
both failing
because people say hey you can't drink
and raise your daughter uh i can do both
just took a puff on a parliament line
yeah i said this is this is a
a woman who knows who she is that's what
i like
you ever meet somebody who just knows
who they are like this woman knows who
she is
so comforting in a sea of pretenders
everybody trying on a different face to
please the masses
not this lady she knew who she was
she knew her limitations and apparently
she didn't have many
i can do both
there was not a skintill of harney she
was not kidding
she was deadly serious
i used to go to something called the
international buffet in between classes
which was an asian fusion buffet which
means that there was sushi but also
french fries
asian fusion sushi but also
have an ice cream cone miso soup
but how about a chicken nugget asian
fusion
international buffet garden city long
island
fusion different types of food spicy
tuna roll
slice of pizza asian fusion and i would
feel
so sick afterwards in class
just because of the soy and the msg and
the sugar
i would feel so sick i remember once i
went in and vomited
in the bathroom and i vomited on my on
my shirt
and i just walked back in without a care
and someone looked at me and went did
you just vomit and i went yeah and they
just laughed
that's how shot i was
and i wish i wish till this day i'm like
had i gone to a college i would have
came out of the closet earlier i would
have been
happier i would not be funny i would not
have bought that house
i would not have destroyed my life and
then who the [ __ ] would want to listen
to those stories
oh i went to a college in new england
and you know i met
carl or whatever and we've been happy
ever since
breeding [ __ ] you know australian
shepherds
and by the way [ __ ] monster shakes in
palm springs
these two gay ogres i hate these two
people
these are these the two most ogre these
two gay ogres
who found each other and open up this
shitty frozen yogurt shop that serves
this thing called
dole whip dole whip is sorbet that comes
out of the frozen yogurt machine
it is disgusting nobody wants it
and it it's for like toothless elderly
people
i don't even know who it's for it's for
latinx people
and me and ben went in there today
because we had to get candles in the cv
ass
i thought maybe we'll just get a little
frozen yogurt and then the frozen yogurt
was literally not frozen it was it
described the texture of it
it's like cream that's expired in the
fridge that you pour out of a little
carton
this is like the third time i've walked
in there and i've said to the guy you
can't
run the place like this like
i don't know what you and your boyfriend
are doing here you and your husband
you're just getting [ __ ] hopped up on
poppers and [ __ ] each other in the
back
i don't know what you're doing but this
is like a business don't you have a
business license
you are both monsters at least there you
can't sue them for false advertising
monster shanks two [ __ ] monsters i've
seen him and his husband in there
together
it's a real [ __ ] interesting
but [ __ ] them but that's the thing
i just i just feel a lot like i don't
know why this feels like a very
it feels like high school to college it
feels like it's weird not that kamal and
biden or college don't [ __ ] please don't
give me any of that [ __ ] i'm not saying
that
i'm saying this feels like a very weird
transition between like people that are
still pretending that nothing's going to
change
and people that are understanding that a
lot so much is going to change
in the next 12 to 16 months i think
people's heads are going to [ __ ] spin
i think people's heads are gonna [ __ ]
spin with the amount of change coming
get [ __ ] ready those tick tock kids
are getting ready they're trying to
[ __ ]
start businesses good for them they're
taking their hoodies off and they're
trying to [ __ ] be angel investors
i mean it's an absurd society
but this is what where we're at